all right this was something that peter
king mentioned
over the weekend that the nfl was going
to consider on tuesday the owners
considered it and they passed it
a proposal
to incentivize the development of
candidates who would become
coaches
and general managers minority candidates
working their way through the pipeline
and so and the best example is this if
the chiefs lose offensive coordinator
eric b enemy to a head coaching job with
say the texans or the falcons next year
the chiefs get
two third round compensatory draft picks
one in 2021 one in 2022 and that applies
if you have employed the individual
at least two years
whether you lose them to a head coaching
position or a gm job it's the incentive
to have a diverse and inclusive and
robust
developmental program
people you're giving responsibility to
people you are grooming there's no
incentive for the team that makes the
hire remember when they suggested that
chris earlier this year yeah it was a
lot of pushback it it and as tony dungy
told me at the time i interviewed him
for a good 25 minutes on this remember
why are you rewarding someone for doing
the right thing right there's a stigma
attached to it as you walk through the
door oh you only did this to get some
draft picks so that was the tie breaker
wait a minute what about you wanted the
best candidate so i like that they
didn't go that route there's going to be
pushback though that there's any type of
compensation
to to create an environment that teams
should want to create anyway but it's
gotten so bad yeah i don't want to say
it's gotten bad it was always bad it
really hasn't improved much over the
last generation i think it's worth a try
to see if it does
in my mind chris shift away from the
who you know and who you're right that's
the problem
just simply
giving out these jobs based on merit no
that that that's exactly it that's where
i think it has to be done i mean i i do
i like the idea of this i do
you know i i think there's a lot of
positives there
really for for the whole league and
everything and hopefully we can do this
to jump-start it and then we don't have
to have this in a few years to where
it's finally like hey you know brian
flores and chris gear you know man two
black guys they're kind of awesome down
there in the miami team maybe i should
too maybe i shouldn't just hire guys
because they're they're white and i feel
more comfortable or to the bigger issue
to like you have said the biggest thing
is just the culture of the community
coaching community in the nfl and i'm
not saying this to disrespect anybody
but yeah for the most part it's long
rooted in you know family histories and
it is about who you know it's not about
what you know it's in fact all about who
you know and of course through that yeah
there's it's been a lot of white people
who have been running football teams for
a long long time so who do they know
more white people more times than not
and that's what happens in these
buildings so you know from that aspect i
like it the one question i'll have and i
saw that
it's in here in our sheets anyway so you
probably have been thinking about this
too you know if you're like gonna lose
eric the enemy right and let's just say
the chargers want to hire him you know
are they gonna be scared to hire him
because now they know the chiefs are
gonna get two extra picks you know i i
would hope not just because they're
gonna cut off their own nose to spite
their face right hey eric bienname's the
best choice take him no matter what but
i just guess that little unintended
consequence does come to my mind just a
little well i i if the enemy's going
anyway
it doesn't matter the chiefs are still
getting the two third round compensatory
picks that's a good i think what becomes
an issue
is where
let's say the chargers let's say the
enemy wasn't a hot candidate but the
chargers know
from facing the chiefs twice per year
this guy's got something he's not he's
not an a-lister right yet but he could
become one
maybe we and and i think in that
situation grabbing away a talented
assistant oh yeah they're going to get a
couple of third-round competitory picks
oh well they're losing that's the red
that's the enemy and we're picking up
eric the enemy so fine get your two
third round compensatory picks that's
the answer you're right
but in a sport where everything gets
analyzed and scrutinized and strategized
you are gonna have those conversations
you are going to stop and say
wait a minute wait a minute what are the
what are all the consequences of hiring
this guy we're giving a division rival
two third round picks if we hire him are
we comfortable with that
and it would be foolish to think that
football teams that understand you look
at all the rules all the consequences
all the
the various issues that may arise and
and you factor them into your decision
you know is it determinative no because
again i'd rather get
a great assistant from one of my rivals
than worry about my rival getting two
third round compensatory picks but those
could be valuable picks yeah you could
be seeing
uh your your rival pick up a couple of
key players that will be a thorn in your
side for years to come yeah no i think
that's it but i think you answered it i
think you're right
the fact that you first off want to hire
the guy because you think he's talented
and he gives your team the advantage
second off yeah you might lose those
picks but i think your point about wait
we've taken a great coach off that
team's roster too so yeah they got two
picks but we took a great coach away i
think there's some merit in that either
way i like the idea i don't think it's
being disrespectful to anybody here i
wish we weren't having the conversation
but like you said it's just gotten crazy
it's out of touch and uh something needs
to be done there to just just jump start
it a little bit here in this league
and let's just be clear about how this
all got rolling back in 2002 the rooney
rule emerged in response to a very clear
threat of imminent litigation that had
gotten so bad and the evidence was so
clear all they had to find was a
plaintiff and and the problem is and
this is where the nfl
will always ultimately benefit from a
structure that doesn't result
in
proper representation in the coaching
ranks and the general manager ranks of
minority candidates even though 70 of
the players are minorities the idea that
no one
is going to give up
his career as an assistant coach
to be the one who carries the flag for
the lawsuit against the nfl because at
the end of the day
you become the coaching equivalent of
colin kaepernick if you're the one who
sues the nfl for racial discrimination
right you just are and and i think the
perfect plaintiff would be maybe an
older
coach who's been passed over multiple
times who's maybe thinking about
retiring anyway and who knows hey maybe
you can throw in an age discrimination
claim because i think age discrimination
is as prevalent if not more prevalent in
the nfl than than any type of a racial
bias that has manifested itself over the
past 20 years or
well prior to that but this all started
because the nfl was afraid of getting
sued and we're only going to see truly
meaningful change
in any american business if they're
doing things whatever the industry
whatever the company whatever the
context if they're doing something they
shouldn't do the threat of litigation
viable litigation non-frivolous
litigation
that is what's going to get you to
change behavior and people like to
complain about the legal system all the
time except when of course they want to
use it then it's great but you know the
very people who are rushing into court
now are the people who hate the legal
system they hate getting sued a
frivolous lawsuit is any lawsuit filed
against me right
having the threat of litigation is the
thing that keeps billion dollar
businesses in line which chris is why
they hate it so much they want to
control everything they don't want
anyone telling them what not to do
having the ability of the average person
to go into court
and to force that billion dollar
business to answer tough questions and
be accountable they hate it except when
they want to use it then they love it
yeah well i i mean
you're right i get that i definitely do
um
maybe maybe one day it'll take that kind
of action we'll see we'll see where this
goes here you know i really
it is disappointing the last few years
you know i always sit there and still
think about eric b enemy whenever we
have this type of conversation the fact
that there was just no major interest in
him last year really bothered me it
really did he's got everything about it
and we've just seen too many good
african-american coaches either passed
over
or mistreated i mean come on i mean
what's jim caldwell right i mean that's
an embarrassment to the nfl and that's
an embarrassment i don't know another
way to say it guy was a good coach he
went to the super bowl goes to detroit
man they were better than than now
but yet he was looked at a bad thing and
let's fire him and get him out of here i
mean he was going to the playoffs and
all that so that's where uh it just
isn't a good look for the nfl and i'm
glad they're trying to take some action
here and get this right
plenty of companies have a policy that
prohibits any form of nepotism
it really is astounding to me
that nfl teams never blink an eye about
coaches
hiring their children never blink an eye
yeah it's it's almost encouraged at this
point and i remember one of the things
that marty schottenheimer now maybe this
was just a pretext because aj smith
wanted to get rid of him anyway but i
think schottenheimer wanted to hire a
brother or something like that and and
aj smith wouldn't let him and that
contributed to the dysfunction and the
ultimate falling out but most teams
don't have any prohibition whatsoever
on hiring your kids and i understand
that coaches who have been absent
for the 18 years that the child was
growing up feel like this is a way to
make up for it by spending instead of no
hours per day with the kid they're now
spending 20 hours a day with the kid
because they're working elbow to elbow
to get the game plan ready for this
weekend but i'm surprised that
that the nfl
because let me tell you if you want to
enhance
the pipeline of minority candidates
one way to do it is to say to the white
coach you can't hire your kid yeah
period i know that's that that would be
that would create a job that would go to
someone based on merit right not based
on
genetics right like maybe your kid can
get hired but not by you where you work
or something like that i mean that
that's where it is tricky you know and
of course hey there's a lot of people
out there that are the coach's son who
are very good at the job too i mean
there is something to that too this is
where it's a tricky conversation right i
mean because you've been around it your
whole life just like kyle it's the
family the only reason kyle's so good
right he's been around it his whole life
he is more qualified than anyone else
that right so even if you're
so that's where it's a really tricky one
you know it really is but yeah we have
other instances where you know we have
certain coaches who
in the past few years go and take
coordinator jobs or whatever and it's
really just about setting their son up
so he can take over and now i'll get out
of the game but now my son was left in a
good spot i took that job just to set
him up and now i'm out of the game and
my son's doing well you know that's
where
it is a little tricky and i don't know
how you fix that i really don't that's a
tough discussion there
yeah and and uh look i've heard stories
over the years about certain coaches who
just hang around that one extra year
hoping that that extra year
gives the sun
enough of an opportunity right to prove
that he belongs right so that he doesn't
need to be tied to dad
he can go do this on his own somewhere
and sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't when i get more
than anything mike and then just in my
experience is how many people
are in the league or in the front
offices again not even
relationships but just about who you
know like not never been involved in
football in any capacity
but dad was rich and powerful and i
called dad and i said i want to work for
an nfl team and he called the owner and
now i'm in the front office i don't know
which way is which on the football field
but now i have a job and that to me is
more of an issue than the family job you
know i've told you that i just i've seen
it too much oh how'd you get this job oh
my dad's the lawyer for the owner how
did you get this job my dad's the
dentist for the owner i mean it's just
like what okay great do you know what a
football looks like yeah i've seen one
once before oh great now you're going to
call in shots here that's where i get
livid when i start to get into those
conversations are you talking about
front office jobs that are related to
football or front office jobs related to
business no football
no it's a football too yes football all
football i'm talking about i'm not
talking about yes if it was for you know
business purposes that's a different
angle but
that to me is where i i get very
frustrated when i hear those kind of
stories throughout the nfl
well and so many businesses in america
are driven by that who you know and who
you're related to and it's especially
prevalent in the nfl
what the owners passed yesterday is
aimed at pushing against that and let's
hope that it does the nfl needs to do it
because it's the right thing regardless
of litigation risk it's the right thing
to do the litigation system there is to
encourage you
to do the right thing but sometimes
maybe you do the right thing even
without worrying about getting sued if
you don't do the right thing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports